- I heard that you said "Rocky"
couldn't have existed without
Carl Weathers, right?
- No, I'm, you know, it-
first of all, Rocky's a, oh, I know.
- [Kelly] Look at that
photo, it's so iconic, wow.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he was amaze-
I couldn't find anyone to play the part.
No one had all the tools.
Either the voice was too high or their,
they weren't big enough or
they weren't athletic enough.
It's really hard to find
everything in a person.
So it was about eight o'clock at night
and the guy I wanted, so then he quit
because he wants to go in
a bicycle race competition.
I went, "Really?"
So obviously he was not a serious actor.
He was a physical type.
So I'm sitting there and at
8:30, this fellow comes in
and he's mad, like, "What am I here for?"
I mean, 'cause no one gets a-
like you don't have an
audition at 8:30 at night.
You're, like, at the bottom of the barrel,
you know what I mean?
- Oh.
- You know what I mean, it's-
- I didn't-
- Like noon, lunch.
- Know that, oh okay.
It's, like, 8:30.
- Oh.
- So he comes in,
they pulled him off a
plane going to Oakland.
So he's coming and he's fired up.
"All right, what do I do?"
I go, "Voice good.
"Voice is good.
(audience and Kelly laughs)
Good, check that."
He goes, and he takes his jacket off,
shoulders forever,
(audience chuckles)
- [Kelly] Check.
- Check, and then he looked,
I went, "Good looking." you know, nice.
I didn't expect that, you
know, 'cause he is a boxer.
- Tough.
- And then we start,
and tough, then we started to
get up and I'm telling you,
and he goes, "Pow, pow, pow."
I go (censored) damn,
and I go, "It's like
(audience and Kelly laughs)
a woodpecker hit me."
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Check.
And then he goes,
"I would've done better if you
at least hired a real actor
instead of, what do you do,
what's this guy do, work in the office?"
I go, "No, he's Rocky." he went,
(audience moans)
"All right, how you
doing Rocky?" he's like,
(audience and Kelly laughs)
there was, and I go-
- This guy.
- "Arrogant, got it."
(audience laughs)
- But you need him-
- This guy that works
in the office.
- You know what I mean.
I wanted that-
- Yeah.
- I wanted him to have this,
like Muhammad Ali.
- (sighs) Ah.
- But he had it all, he had charm,
he had this, he had heart, he had soul.
So I was stunned when it
happened, I was, like, crushed.
I didn't think he would ever die.
You know, he is like superman.
Yeah, so I look back now with
fond, fond, fond memories.
'Cause it's never gonna happen.
You know what happens, you
have those seminal moments,
those crossroads, and it's like-
- And certain Chemistry
on certain things.
- Yeah, it's just,
it's impossible to duplicate.
You know, it's like if-
- Yeah I know.
- They take a group,
and let's say the Rolling Stones, right.
You take Mick Jagger out, it's over.
You take Mick Jagger, the solo.
I don't think it works either.
There's something about-
- They fit.
- That combination that was so unique
that you can't mess with it.
- Yeah.
- And I think that happened with Rocky.
Everybody in it was, like,
sort of born to play the part.
- Yeah.
- Hey.
- [Kelly] I love it, and when it works out
like that, that's why it's so successful.
- Yeah, it is, it is.